presumptious me to say this but I
thought it was important
that the president United States be here
in a day in the attack began
because as the president remember
I was warning the world that he was
going to attack a certain of it
and uh I thought it was critical that
there would not be any doubt none
whatsoever about U.S support for Ukraine
and their war against the broom attack
by Russia you know this could be back in
key but I was telling the president one
of my there were staff members on the
flight from Washington
[Music]
and I had to stop and think it's my
eighth trip
and much has changed much of a bad of
the invasion but also
between Ukrainian people have stepped up
in a way that a few people ever had when
they're in the fence and have apparently
now also embraced the Notions of
democracy no longer a discussion is
about whether or not certain privileged
people have control and uh you know when
I bring greetings and Goodwill
[Music]
and for all the disagreement we have in
our Congress
for some issues that there is a
significant agreement that support for
Ukraine okay this is so much larger than
just a crane
it's about freedom of democracy and New
York it's about creating democracy a bit
large
and
all the American people I I know that
so many have kept Ukrainian people
particularly women and children in their
prayers seeing what's happening they
can't fathom the idea of the shelving
knife the showing of everything new
orphanages to to schools through the
like it's barbaric
and I'm here to show our unwavering
support for the nation's Independence
there's sovereignty and uh and
territorial integrity and uh today I
hope we're going to have a chance to
discuss
how the United States and our allies by
keeping constant contact with our
partners came most effectively to
support you and your grabbing your cause
Mr President I look forward to
discussing all this and then addressing
the world with you afterwards but
again
the admiration
for the people of Ukraine ordinary
hard-working citizens
and we're never trying to be military
when they stepped up they assessed this
is beyond heroic and the whole world was
looking all over there